el Papa Francisco ha sido hospitalizado
en la tarde de este miércoles en un
hospital Romano una información
confirmada en un comunicado oficial en
el cual el Vaticano indica que En días
pasados el pontífice ha lamentado
algunas dificultades respiratorias razón
por la cual fue trasladado a una
estructura sanitaria situada en el sur
de Roma para efectuar algunos controles
médicos El Vaticano precisa que el papa
no tiene covid pero no da más detalles
sobre el tipo de exámenes a los cuales
será sometido el jefe de la Iglesia
Católica ni sobre la gravedad de su
estado de salud del pontífice deberá
permanecer hospitalizado por varios días
dice el comunicado oficial las
audiencias previstas en los próximos
días han sido canceladas la última
hospitalización de Francisco fue en
julio de 2021 cuando fue sometido a una
operación de intestino en la cual le
retiraron treinta y tres centímetros de
colon Y seguramente esta nueva
hospitalización genera una ola de
preocupación con respecto a la salud del
jefe de la iglesia católica